all right this you have to see and I
have to admit this this gives me great
pleasure Doug mastriano is this big lie
a proponent who was at the Capitol on
January 6th and he is the Republican
nominee for being the governor of the
state of Pennsylvania it would be a
disaster if Doug mastriano were to
become the governor of Pennsylvania but
the good news is his campaign isn't
doing very well apparently desperate to
try to fix it the Philadelphia Inquirer
reports that Doug mastriano is now
planning 40 days of fasting and prayer
to try to save his campaign
I love this for two reasons number one
he's losing and he's desperate and
that's great and it's good news for the
people of Pennsylvania but also fasting
and prayer aren't going to change the
polls for him it's not actually going to
do anything so I say do 80 Days of
fasting and prayer of course there's not
80 days left before the uh before the
election the article writes the
Republican gubernatorial candidate is
losing some support among Republican
allies as his cash-strapped campaign
turns to Twitter memes and apparently
divine intervention
you these people are a joke it was built
as a blockbuster but it ended up a flop
if Doug mastriano's big rally last
weekend were a movie it's Rotten
Tomatoes score would be in the single
digits only a few dozen supporters
joined the Republican state senator on
the steps of the Capitol building in
Harrisburg some of them members of a
militia group
the photos looked bad because it was bad
and the Press coverage was brutal so
what is he doing now by the way here's a
picture of the rally I'm sure it's like
there's almost no one it looks like it's
just intern orientation day
uh at the Capitol
now with the election 41 days away
the head of a conservative group airing
anti-shapiro ads remember Shapiro is the
Democrat who we should all just vote for
if you live in Pennsylvania because he's
a completely uncontroversial reasonable
candidate is questioning mastriano's
tactics particularly his insistence on
campaigning within an echo chamber etc
etc
so what is it that is going on now
on Monday night
mastriano's campaign posted on Facebook
a photo of two hands under the words 40
days of fasting and prayer with the
dates September 29 through November 8th
election day interceding for our
elections our state and our nation it
stated along with a verse from the book
of Isaiah mastriano wrote in the post
starting in a few days it'll be my honor
to fast with you
now as the article points out it's
unclear who mastriano expects to start
fasting on Thursday
but this is all part of this Christian
nationalist Ideology Now of course this
isn't going to do anything for him and
so my messages do it do it the message
to the voters is don't assume that we
have this in the bag no risks can be
taken here's the way that the polling is
looking right now mastriano versus Josh
Shapiro on average on average Shapiro is
leading by 9.3 almost a double-digit
lead this is a major major deal because
the risk if mastriano became the
governor is that Democrats lose the
White House in 2024. I know that some of
you might find that hyperbolic it is not
hyperbolic Pennsylvania is a state
on Which presidential elections can
hinge
presidential election is not going to
hinge on Rhode Island
it's not going to hinge on South Dakota
we know how those are going to go
many scenarios have presidential
elections depending on Pennsylvania
if Doug mastriano wins in November
and then in 2024 a Democrat narrowly
wins the presidential election in
Pennsylvania be it Joe Biden or whoever
is the nominee mastriano will try to
steal Pennsylvania for republicans and
so the consequences are absolutely
massive so it is so great that Shapiro
is up nearly double digits but
do not assume we have this in the bag
the risk is too great this one is just
so so important that no risks can be
taken now as far as Josh Shapiro and
we're going to have coverage of the
mastriano versus Shapiro debate let me
remind myself when that is
uh let's see I'm checking out my
calendar
it is I don't know what it is
is it tomorrow no work I'll let you know
when that debate is okay we're gonna
have the debate Josh Shapiro is not a
Democrat that pennsylvanians have to
kind of turn their nose up and say well
I'm reluctantly voting for Josh Shapiro
he's not the most Progressive Democratic
candidate but he's super smart
he's reasonable he's Common Sense he's
completely uncontroversial he's actually
a fine choice for governor of
Pennsylvania so it's all laughable the
prayer is not going to get masteriano to
catch up the 10-point deficit the
fasting certainly is not let them do it
encourage them to do it but let's not
assume that this is in the bag because
it is so important a race and we don't
want to give them any opportunity
I have a really tough time finding dress
shirts I like they're either
uncomfortable or they're tight or
they're loose or hot or itchy and that's
why it's been so great to discover the
commuter shirts made by our fantastic
sponsor Rhone rhone's commuter shirt is
a reinvention of the men's dress shirt
it's the most comfortable dress shirt
I've worn Roan's comfortable four-way
stretch fabric provides the
breathability and the flexibility that
leaves you free to enjoy what life
throws your way could be a long day at
work could be brunch with the family
you're just going to be comfortable and
that's so important with rhone's wrinkle
release technology the wrinkles
disappear as you stretch and wear the
shirt which is very convenient and Rhone
is 100 machine washable so you can skip
the dry cleaning altogether I've had a
great experience with Rhone the shirts
are appropriate if you want want to look
nice or somewhat formal
I rarely need to and they're just as
good as a comfortable t-shirt when you
want to relax or just move around in it
go to rhone.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman to get 20 off the most
comfortable shirt you'll ever own the
link is down below